j'appelle pour ce premier gage j'appelle
gilles verdez et benjamin castaldi
je mélange attaque son jeu mélange bien
entendu je mélange regarder pour me
disent
tu me lis tu as possible
stop très bien attention qui veut
prendre la cardio
mais ici gilles alors la faire par ordre
alphabétique vers dsk stabi système
montre la carte 1 6
à 10 c'est donc benjamin castaldi
benjamin castaldi c'est quoi c'est ça ce
sont des algues voilà donc voilà non non
mais non mais non mais non au missile à
la caméra et là tu fais de la télé
depuis combien d'années où là bas dans
ton slip
et ce dans la piscine se bat b mais
attention pas de faire mal tu voi pa ka
poids de forme et il est con mais qui
découvre ce pas possible mais quel
abruti mais quel abruti mais sans
rigoler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez le comme à regarder le cabinet
sexy regardez le cabinet sexy regardez
regardez moi ça non mais ça ils
regardent les années c'est qu'il essaie
mais tu sais que tu es beaucoup plus
beaux mouillé non mais sans déconner
mais c'est vrai quand on sait que c'est
dégueulasse autoroute est pas mal mais
c'est bien est ce que tu vas pas être
tout embrouiller toit en fait mais je te
jure merci les lunettes castadi
attention attention deuxième gages
à la suis là il est fou tu l'as déjà on
va le faire plusieurs fois
je suis là on va le faire plusieurs fois
je vous explique il y en a deux qui vont
se présenter ici et vous allez devoir
refaire la scène culte de loana dans la
piscine avec le ou le partenaire de
votre choix donc celui qui perd choisira
le ou la partenaire de son choix pour
aller dans la piscine bien sûr avec son
consentement et refaire offert la scène
de la piscine à cloyne
les deux protagonistes
de ce nouveau défi qu'est ce tu mets tu
sors d'où toi
je vois partir de là là mais qu'est-ce
qui fait aimer ça rigolait smap au team
les deux protagonistes sont réponds
bah oui mais j'ai pensé à toi bien là
bébé l'inquiète pas varié t'arriver de
mal aux gars comme thébaux en plus en
tenue estivale des manies django edwards
a trouvé ton style toi toi si on pouvait
être toute l'année les têtus serait
magnifique c'est arrivé c'est fou ça et
daniel
[Musique]
ci est inquiète mais c'est metz et
inquiète pas mais je t'aiderai et je
vais faire mais je vais faire levier
t'inquiète pas mais si tu t'inquiètes
pas arrête un peu
la plus petite carte mère est donc la
plus petite carte bain dans la piscine
et choisi la personne de son choix pour
aller faire la scène de loana dans la
piscine rappeler avec jean pascal et
non pas jusqu'au bout quand même pas
mettre papa dans maman n'y pas pas dans
ma part j'aurais doit oui jean pascal ça
n'a rien à voir c'est un ami attention
vous me dis stop
hatier attention qui dit mardi attendre
deux mois la carte donne moi ta carte
non tu me la donne
je sens qu'on va voir daniel dans la
piscine
1 2 je rappelle que c'est la plus petite
carte qui perd
huawei très bon tu est sauvé
[Applaudissements]
daniel t'inquiète pas tu vas te mettre
au bord d'un quai de toi à mes côtés
aulas attend déjà tu doit se dire ton
partenaire dont j'aurais dois tu vois le
choix regardent ils sont magnifiques tu
peux reprendre benjamin qui bientôt
magazine ça fait longtemps que j'avais
le docteur envie non plus de
noms mais tu fais ce que tu fais ce que
tu veux tu peux reprendre et mon
choisy que tu peux choisir si tu veux je
suis à dix ce que tu veux dans le panel
est là le panel est là et le palais tu
peux prendre mathieu
membrane une fille vraiment besoin d'une
fillette à la droite choisir d
une fois
alors fais toi plaisir à les battre
alors on s'était préparés nomination
d'elias et à guillaume je pense
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît mettez daniel dans la
piscine s'il vous plaît vas-y occupe toi
daniel voilà souplet attendait non mais
prend là par la main quand la pala
je sens que ça va être chaud
l'esata soir attends attends machine
est inquiète pas trop si c'est bon
[Musique]
[Rires]
allez m'aider ou la vessie live vous
êtes dans la piscine la piscine
[Rires]
mais non mais
pourquoi ténors mais non je vais mettre
ça dans la piscine va s'asseoir dans la
piscine si j'y arrive et si tu as tu te
trouves pas que l'on ne tombe pas tout
voilà assis toi là dessus
attention daniel tout est mort voilà
daniel sala
mais toi dans la boue et sur l'a10
à rostov voilà maintenant on
va tomber et on ait envie de refaire la
scène de l'art ici
c'était
daniel métraud de la babouche
[Musique]
sera celui-là il est là gilles et la
chine et la wii non non non ça ne me
sens pas comme ça c'est pas non plus
mais non mais personne n'a pas retomber
dans l'ornière mais dans l'eau il ya
deux sentiments
gilles ne tenait pas sur l espèce de
recul mais non le fait de les nommer
c'est pas possible
il ne fait pas fausse et daniel naud et
met toi bien allonger l'âge est là
et bien c'est bien
nantis diallo mais la farce et daniel
qui fait ce qu'il peut a témoigné le
chalut micro des passionnés on
les entend pas la paix oui moi aussi et
puis le temps qui font cette fille das
ces marchés une galoche en galoche
[Applaudissements]
et là des lots
[Musique]
aléatoires
avancé mais pas là
appelez ça va ça va passer attention
attention
et il attention bah c'est bon c'est bon
c'est passé dans cette fois-ci attention
s'est passé ça y est
c'est à ces mots s'est passé s'est passé
s'est passé j'ai passé bravo danièle
les chéris attention troisième défi
troisième défi c'est le gage
eddy mitchell
eddy mitchell c'est très simple il va
falloir y laissa monsieur la chanter
couleur menthe à l'eau en buvant et
motta l'eau dans la piscine
les deux protagonistes
sont
d'accord
guillaume genton
et
valérie mais
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vous qui décidez
la plus grande où la plus petite on ne
va pas la plus grande n'est pas d'accord
donc à la romieu avec aplomb n'y va pas
vous me dites stop
stop
qui veut pour la première
allée violemment
sa 101 guillaume genton dans la piscine
pour est le
même entre la stib et u14 valérie benaïm
ce sera votre quartier et a touché la
touche et la fête comme ça
dit aux gens dont
tu vas chacha mais l'homme est non mais
tu vas te faire mal mais qui sait qu'on
vous comprenez pas qu'à pas de
fontgrande le parc beaudet qui veulent
faire des plongeons nous mais qu'ils
sont bêtes
je crois qu'ils attendent dans les
tombeaux nitoo tu m'as de la perruque
comme sa
sortie à peine sorti de l'eau
et tu chantes un
cadeau moi j'étais
perdu
mais bon à la menthe à l'eau
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est cali
incroyable merci
à plusieurs leaders
moi j'ai trop
[Musique]
fait attention on va passer maintenant
sur le gage titanic
titanic
j'appelle raymond s'est pas bâti
le gacci tandis que c'est très simple on
remplit ton maillot de 400 et tu sautes
dans la piscine entendu ces lignes on
appris ton maillot de caleçons le glaçon
j
ai castaldi
nous allons suivre attention la plus
petite où la plante la plus grande pour
changer c'est qu'il va la plus grande
joie du petit à petit à petit tu penses
à la wave à dans le directoire pas un
vitrail annonça sa là tu me la donnes la
pop
castagné une fois
[Applaudissements]
tu vas santé
c'est
[Musique]
je suis qualifié
sarah cattani c'est pas la fille de m
qui va manger la grosse
bravo benjamin magana qui jouent le jeu
bravo madame
aa2 pas clown armée c'est pas possible
nan mais c'est horrible sans déconner et
c'est horrible selon m si rory monsieur
rim attention
on va maintenant faire le gage les dents
de l'amour on à poisson pourri si vous
dînez pour y va falloir aller dans l'eau
avec la musique des dents de la mer et
faire un smack un poisson qui flottent
dans l'eau
les deux protagonistes sont
géraldine
d'accord chérie tu t'inquiètes pas l
incroyable incroyable mais je me suis tu
allais mais je suis
dans les livres
numériques
ce sera ton dernier si tu gagnerais tu
seras
et géraldine le grand honneur aux femmes
oui très bien je crois ce que c'est la
petite carte qui gagnent ou la plus
grande c'est la plus petite qui qui fait
le cas d'accord ça sans poinçon
[Rires]
voici sa touche pas car tu y es ses
touches ta carte
et m'était venue comme aujourd'hui en
câble pouet pouet
[Rires]
attends je retouche ça c'est serré on
embrasse un troisième
gîte ma chérie les ados
alors ça consiste en quoi
[Rires]
alors d'un grossiste en quoi alors
je rajoute jordi est ce que je peux
changer de cage oui oui je me sers jean
edouard et loana dans la piscine
j'accepte je préfère avec qui avec ba1
et
d'habitude je suis intransigeant sur les
rails d'un
ami gérad et si je vous comme de
l'amitié je vous nomme
rédactrice en chef d'édition
fait à partir de maintenant c'est vous
qui sait rédactrice en chef de
l'émission de tunnels à venir
béatrice est ce que tu es d'accord
ça consiste en quoi c'est très simple
vous allez vous faire un bisou sensuelle
mais oui son
baiser sur la bouche sensuelle après
elle dit où elles voudront asie où elle
vous donc dans la piscine par contre et
c'est nous qui payons c'est à dire que
je veux d'abord
et voilà c'est pas direct on se smacks
héros locaux que ce soit un peu voilà je
vais en vue de la pyramide c'est toi la
metteuse en scène c'est toi qui fais ta
doit débuter au calme toi tu s'il te
plaît est en train de nous encore des
dessins à
laisser aller c'est pas d'étaler sa qui
pointe la gamme de toi calme-toi l
attention
c'est arrivé est un fait
inquiète pas
alors mettez moi à l'achat car vous êtes
au début des mois cette [ __ ] de boue
et
ça c'est à qui ça
témoin cette frites à olhao la doublette
béatrice vont mettre la balle à battre
là-bas vous fait connaissance dans la
piscine
qu'est ce qui
vous plaît on veut voir cette musique
m'est témoin d'un truc bob decout
[Rires]
redden et fait tourner deuil
alors pour y danser un peu
[Rires]
attendez attendez attendez pour casser
l'ambiance fait rentrer daniel
attention allez-y éclat mais c'est très
simple c'est géraldine qui gère c'est la
méthode c'est la metteuse en scène c'est
l'abbé tous dansé
sur la tête de ma mère
[Rires]
cioni
toit de loin
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
j'ai raté je tiens à féliciter gérard
gélas dean hum je double votre cas si
aujourd'hui
c'est nt1
[Applaudissements]
et je tiens tu dis mieux maintenant
géraldine a lancé à nouveau le jeu dans
le jeu c'est à dire que si le gage ne
vous plaît pas vous pouvez remplacer par
sodica se gâte c'est contre galles c'est
contre gage par se gâtent là avec la
personne de votre choix bien entendu
nous alors attention je crois qu'on
commence à être bien on commence est pas
mal attention prochain gage trop chang
hd et chérie le
nom ça c'est nul ça c'est nul ah oui
ah oui d'accord
le bas bouche à bouche c'est très simple
il va falloir sauver une babouche au
fond de la piscine et lui faire un
bouche-à-bouche
vous pouvez vous pouvez changer pas levé
le chantier par le guen pour extorquer
par le gage de la piscine pour une
journée par gas la piscine j'appelle et
appelle delphine n'aspire
et j'appelle
[Rires]
j'appelle match
tu fais tu fais un cadeau
mais n'ont abattu le fellah s'inquiète
pas
t'inquiète tape un boulot
tu veux danser dont 6
alors toi est ce qu'on peut faire un
truc spécial blida mais non je te mets
là bas au bout de la piscine ou à la mer
parce que tu attends là dessus et euros
en europe attention gros ramener la
perche palapa salle de bain à bulles à
la tâche mais je fais ça je prends un
tuyau on a tous bien du même nom mais si
je te mets là bas et j'en
attends tu m'a dit tu m'as dit oui non
pado et c'est le thème de la journée non
c'est pas tes seins journée c'était la
première partie n'ont pas d'eau
non non je te fais tout ce
qui va lui parler non non non pas ben
ali ne tue la déléguée syndicale
turinois n'ont pas de poids dont il a
fait une dérogation pour toi au panorama
accepter que tu vas bradant ont
fait un truc perso là ils sont tous là
ils sont prêts mais dans ce cas là alors
tout le monde personne ne le fait
oui bah oui c'est une fois dubaï tout au
plus est peut-être que tu vas gagner 1
go n'ont
fait que rémois toujours gagné jusqu'à
présent mais c'est quoi ton problème
attention la non non non non non non non
non ça nage toujours l'homme sinon moi
parlions tous les auscitains n'y a pas
de hordes au logis j'en ai parlé non
non tu ne passes pas non plus vraiment
eu lui pas sinon mathieu tu donnes ton
café tu veux mon madone
ça va une fois que j'ai dit non une fois
non non non non si on perd mais c'est
très bien où joue j'ai fait deux choses
[Rires]
mélo ses mots ni de me wade qui l'attend
dans l'eau j'ai comme ça comme ça
d'où cette fois hélas mais non
oui mais pas tout faire
non
juste un doute je te dis oui 12 cents à
l'ajout d'une opa j'ai raté béatrice
retourner dans l'eau
ma chérie
tu as donc affronter qui tu veux c'est
ok les signes qui je veux
aller
bien sûr tu peux changer de langage ok
par celui que tu désires est ce que
j'avais déjà une idée pour le gaz
j'ai l'impression que c'était mon show
commence à me traiter mais ça commence à
me faire fortune
delphine
dessine à tort me donne je me donne
aucun nom mais 57 le grand
tu me l'as tu la montre c'est ça la
touche à tout cela tout cela
c'est bien parti
tout cela touche là
mais non mais non y
ait des faits m'engage alors tu peux
changer de gamme avec la personne de ton
choix mêmes gages comme les filles elles
ont fait avec grand plaisir je vais
faire ça
je fais ce que tu veux il ya des think
et la maintenance y
avait bien
10 et moi je sais pas je suis
je bouffe ancrée madame aime pas trop
mettre en place là-bas
je te remets d'aller à l'époque sur les
montures pas taire les foules vers s'il
te plaît les réalisateurs merci les
cadreurs on y va on est là delphine sait
comment
ça va tourner là-bas sur ces parties
alors en revanche on veut ce que vous
voulez c'est vous qui faites votre vie
seulement voilà moi vous savez je suis
là en cas de coup dur
sykes pas de laon sauveteurs à tout
moment bien entendu sur saône avec amour
à dire bah bah
c'est pas douter drague
la seconde est hétéro dans ses missions
mathieu il reste combien
non mais c'est aussi cette émission
c'est devenu jamais sans rigoler j'adore
c'est comme ça
[Rires]
et moi derrière est incroyable
[Musique]
ce
qui se passe à l'est le
bordel
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête dans chaque
camp mais
alors là resté dans la piscine
je vais maintenant je vous le dis je
vais d'ailleurs maintenant faire un
dernier couple mixte on va jouer tous
ensemble sortie de la piscine c'est le
dernier vous sortez c'est le dernier
défi c'est ce qu'on appelle de la sts
défi
chacun d'apprendre une carte même mois
les deux plus petites cartes vont se
retrouver dans la piscine est mort huit
mois voilà et vont se faire un câlin
comme il le désire je joue c'est eux qui
voient
les deux plus petites car basse et ben
ouais consentement des deux c'est dire
si vous avez envie de vous faire un
smart fait un smack si vous avez envie
de mon gars là je vous galocher si vous
avez envie de cannes vous qu'est né mais
juste pour me laisser tranquille c'est
tout ce que je vous demande
donc ça veut dire que moi oui oui oui
oui oui c'est possible oui ce n'est pas
une utopie elle a 26 mai venait
wimbledon oui c'est possible oui ben ali
est une étude avait 20 ans mathieu est
ce que tu es sûr que tu peux pas jouer
là c'est sûr donc oui donc là dessus
dans le talent alors mathieu tu veux te
demander de mettre à l'écart tu pars toi
avec ton ce greg
tu quittes la vente donner les chiffres
je mélangeais carte chacun va prendre
une carte chacun son tour les deux plus
petites cartes de l'équipe iront dans
l'eau ok et se feront le câlin de
l'amour éternel
d'accord le câlin de l'amour éternel le
club isérois est ce que c'est moi qui
peux juste retourner les cartes ce alors
vous coupez votre région vous l'aimez
mon slip allez-y menez vous allez vous
faire ce qu'on appelle le cloud
le calme est de la mort
le câlin de l'amour éternel
attention
on va démarrer
dans l'ordre décroissant
vie d'une des aiguilles d'une
démarré dans l'ordre décroissant des
aiguilles d'une montre
on va démarrer et on va faire l'ordre
alphabétique nos premiers à tirer la
quartier donc à bout alors des fois sans
nom j'avais choisi des crânes et des
croissants si j'ai envie de manger des
croissants donc ta carte si celle-là on
fait en derniers mois ta carte c'est
celle-là rushmore discute pas c'est bon
il a dit jean veut pas
tuer tuer savais tu la gardes tu la
gagnes tu la gagnes et tu mets ta carte
comme ça devant toi devant ton slip
merci regardez les
noms c'est le nom de famille comme on
est au niveau 2 avec art est légal ne
tapait pas bozene à ce que je sache
attention ensuite c'est benjamin
benhaim
donne moi ta carte je suis la touche
tutoyer sa
médaille mais sauvé ya six
médailles mais son
attention
benjamin castaldi tous ta carte c'était
castaldi sera dans la piscine
de tels choix mais quel chat noir mais
quel chat mais jamais le jour mais bon
comme ça m'est égal bien ta carte il te
plaît déjà des fois ça non merde pas les
autres ça attention on a donc après les
gens tombent
banane c'est dans ta carte touche à ton
qu on a su être sauvé
attention pour l'instant pour l'instant
c'est vraiment et benjamins mais bon
raymond bas si on stoppe citoyens de
donner sa possible l'impossible e.on a
ensuite à nomad inaba giral nous donnera
ta carte machine
oui c'est
un autre pas mal ça devrait passer mais
pour l'instant tu es dans la piscine
avec benjamin autant te dire que tu vas
déguster ça ne va pas être possible
c'est ce que disent beaucoup de choses
je vais demander maintenant daniel
moreau venir me rejoindre
arrêtez avec ça fait chier tout le monde
le sais tu tues rappelé à dire a dit
benjamin t'inquiète pas il à défaut
célèbre tu sentiras mais juste 4 comme
ça mais juste à carte comme ça et juste
à carte comme ceci
béatrice rosen et je tirais la carton
d'herning femme est surnommé le tigre
est
béatrice rosen vous remplacer daniel
vous êtes
si
le plus grand malheur qui puisse vous
arriver c'est que gilles verdez firme
une carte plus petit parce qu'après 6 et
d'alpine ou
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est parti
j'ai tué saurait
il ya que delphine et moi qui pourront
sauver les fines vient toucher ta carte
ra position des mains
ou lilas ramdoo lit la porte des lilas
fille tuée dans la piscine
je tire quand même un toit n'est pas
d'abord animé mécanique et dans le cadre
ça passe merci je suis sauvé merci des
séries que je vais demander un appui de
mazères avec le beau gosse des bacs à
sable benjamin castaldi barca c'est pas
possible c'est fou c'est fou
voilà mon chéri et dans le public où
john ont joué son chéri
s'étonne filmé cette scène pour
l'envoyer or là ne dort jamais allez
c'est parti
c'est le boulot régate en au boulot
c'est le boulot et le boulot c'est le
boulot
c'est comme disait gilles le boulot
c'est le boulot
attention c'est quoi la musique
non mais c'est nul c'est mehdi harati
avec lenny kravitz à 1 pour l'instant la
high line qu'il a une tête avec lenny
kravitz
à la glace j'ai fait ça
[Musique]
seidel film qui fait ce qu'elle veut
maintenant je pense que c'est préférable
pour témoin
ouais
excuse moi il n'est pas chez maniatis
allait passer jean louis david non mais
c'est vrai il attend c'est la mort qui
tue lui la région
d'investir d'eric fonction de foot ont
battu par vannes en match il ne peut
rien faire c'est d'attignat son amoureux
dans le public et je peux le comprendre
je pense que ça y est on a eu la réponse
c'était le dernier test
c'est bon ça y est benjamin castaldi
sera donc aux côtés de matthieu du deal
sur matière mykonos ces mots le chercher